I've been talking about a general
relativity and it particular the post
Newtonian relativistic effects. These
are the first things that happen, uh,
as the gravitational field become
strong enough that, uh, uh,
Newton doesn't perfect.
Newton's laws don't perfectly apply.
And let me just summarize those,
uh,
because we're going to see them all
in action, uh, in just a minute.
So here are the post Newtonian effect
of general relativity.
Okay.
Uh,
and the first of them is the precession
of the Para helion just going to list
these.
And this was seen and,
uh,
in the 19th century already.
Yeah.
Uh, and, uh, correctly
interpreted by Einstein. Okay.
Had to do with Mercury's orbit. I
should say this word Para helion. Uh,
that means closest approach to the sun.
Uh,
and so that only applies for planets.
If you have the same,
you can have the same kind of effect
in binary stars are and other things,
in which case, uh, you might, uh,
they call it a Perry Asteron.
That's the closest approach to
a star that isn't the sun. Uh,
or, uh, here's a favorite word
of mine. Peric the lack TACAN.
I liked that one. That's the
closest approach to a galaxy. Uh,
you can have the, the other
side of the orbit, uh,
that is on 180 degrees away from the
Para Galactica and that's called the
[inaudible] con.
Uh,
and you are challenged to use that in a
sentence at any time over break anyone
who successfully does that, uh, uh,
send me an email recounting
the circumstances.
I'll give you an extra point or
something. Uh, all right. Uh, so,
uh, procession of the pair
of helium, that's, that's one
post Newtonian effect. Uh,
another post Newtonian effect
is the deflection of light
by mass just because
mass curved space time.
And so a light will follow
a curve pass. Also, uh,
this was first demonstrated in 1919
by the famous eclipse observations of
Edington.
Yeah.
And it also, uh, is,
has been manifested recently
in the discovery of so
called gravitational lenses
of various kinds
in which the,
uh,
appearance of an object is distorted by
the fact that the light from that object
has to pass by some other
mass on its way to your eye.
And so I have a couple examples here,
which I'd like to show you
of gravitational lenses.
Okay.
Uh, this is the famous
Einstein Cross, so called a,
and what this is, this is just
a, this is just a picture, uh,
I think from the Hubble Space Telescope.
And these four objects here,
uh, are the same object. That's
a quasar. Uh, it's just, uh,
for this purpose of point of light in
the sky, uh, but it's located, it's true.
Location is behind this thing.
This is much closer to you than any
of these guys. This is a galaxy, uh,
about, uh, partway
between us and the Quasar.
And what has happened is if there
were no deflection of light,
you'd see this quasar kind of
right behind the galaxy. Uh,
and in fact it would be hard
to distinguish between the two.
But what has happened is because
there's this galaxy in the way,
the light from the quasar starts coming
this way and then bends around the
galaxy and comes back toward us.
And the same is true up here
and down here and down here.
And so you get four different images
of this quasar of the same quasar.
And they know it's the same points are
because they've taken spectrum the thing,
and it's the exact same spectrum
on all four of these things.
And so these are just four
different images of the
same, uh, of the same object.
And the reason they're not symmetrically
distributed here is because the mass in
this galaxy is not
symmetrically distributed.
And so depending on what path you take,
you get different amounts of deflection.
So that's a classic example
of a Gravitational Lens. Yes,
in principle,
you could see it right through here.
But there are two things about the
path that comes right at us. Uh,
there are two problems with that. One
is, uh, that, uh, for various reason,
these guys are all magnified.
And the one that comes through the
middle is d magnified. Second of all,
it's right in back of the galaxy.
Uh,
but in principle there's a fifth
one down in the middle. That's true.
Yes.
Sorry.
Okay. So let me, let me pause here
and tell you what a quasar is.
A quasar is a quasi stellar object.
What it is,
is it's a very bright source
right in the middle of a galaxy.
And so it's actually a point source
of light. It looks like a star.
Uh, these things turn out
to be what they really are.
It turns out our massive black holes in
the center of galaxies are creating, uh,
creating material from the, from
the galaxy itself. And so they,
but they appear to be very
bright nuclei of galaxies.
And if you could look really hard,
you could see the galaxy,
the background galaxy around this thing.
But in this particular case,
it's way too faint to see, uh, the galaxy.
It has a much larger extent,
uh,
because it's all the stars and all the
stuff in the galaxies is not coming right
from the middle, uh, and uh,
this much closer than those.
And so you can actually see that
it's extended in this case. Yes.
Oh, it's not the black hole
that submitting the light.
It's the material falling into the
black hole that gets heated up.
I'll actually talk about this
on Thursday a little bit.
Other questions about
the Einstein Cross here.
Let me show you another one.
So this is a Hubble space telescope.
Picture of a cluster of galaxies.
See all these different things,
all these extended sources.
Those are all individual
galaxies, galaxies. It turned
out come in clusters. Uh,
and so here's a big bunch of galaxies
and some of the galaxies you see here.
Most of the galaxies, all these
big ones are part of this cluster.
This is a cluster that's
relatively nearby to earth,
but some of the galaxies are actually
not in the cluster. They're much,
much further away. They're in back
of the cluster and these things,
these sort of streaky things you
see all over the place here. Uh,
what these are are galaxies.
There are in back of the
cluster of galaxies whose
light has been lensed when it
passes through the cluster of
galaxies and it's been stretched.
It's because what happened is
this thing here, for example, uh,
ought to be a tiny little galaxy that
you can barely see here except the light
from the top end of the,
of that galaxy got bent up to here.
And the light from the bottom end of
that galaxy got bent down to here. Uh,
and so all, and that's why they're
all sort of in this kind of search.
All these things are kind of circular
around the center of this thing because
this is a very, very massive galaxy. And
that's the thing that's doing Melendez.
And so it effectively distort the
shape of the background galaxy.
And you could see a couple more of them
around this massive galaxy here. Um,
these, uh, are pretty,
but they also can be used
in order to understand, uh,
the distribution of mass inside the galaxy
cluster because the particular way in
which these galaxies are
distorted depends on how,
how much mass there is in this galaxy
cluster and how that mass is distributed.
And so these are used to study the
masses of and mass distributions of,
uh, of galaxy clusters. And so this is a
different kind of gravitational lensing.
Uh, and finally, let me show
you a joke. Um, this is,
uh,
a picture of the Smithsonian
Institute in Washington DC.
Uh,
where there are a group of whether the,
actually the Smithsonian astrophysical
observatory is actually in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
And there,
there are a group of people who study
gravitational lensing and they have taken
this picture and imagined what it would
look like if about halfway between where
you're looking at this building. There
were a black hole, the mass of Saturn,
uh,
and here's what it looks like.
A and all these distortions
are simply due to the, uh,
change in direction caused
by the gravitational force
of this imaginary black
hole. Until you can see what happens. Uh,
the black hole is sort of
right down the middle here. Uh,
and so off at the edges there's
only a little bit of distortion.
And then in the middle
everything goes haywire. Uh,
let me take this back a notch.
Uh, take a look at these two central
towers, this one here and that one.
Uh, and so they're kind of, uh,
what's happened here is that you're seeing
light that has gone out and then been
bent back toward you. So it looks like
the towers over here, but look it,
that same tower is down here. And so
that's like from the tower that went,
that went down and underneath the black
hole and then got pulled back up to grow
to reach your eyes.
So there are two paths from that tower
to your eye and you can see both of them.
Look at this thing here. Uh, what's that?
Let me go back to the original picture.
That's this statue.
And what's happened is light from the top
of the statue has gone up and over the
black hole and come down towards you.
Uh, whoops. Uh, and so here it is.
Uh,
and similarly,
the clouds that were up here
have been bent down, uh,
have gone underneath the black hole and
been bent back up so you can see them
here. And so they worked out all the
distortions of this. Uh, and uh, uh,
so they like to show this kind of amusing
picture. They actually had a movie,
which I couldn't find on the,
uh, on the net last night,
which is too bad,
where they take the black hole and they
kind of move it across the front of this
thing and you can see all the
distortions coming up. Uh,
and so you can have enormous fun with
this kind of thing. Uh, needless to say,
this is not, this particular picture
has not ever actually been observed.
That's calculated, not, uh,
uh, not actually observed.
Uh,
but you can see the kinds of bizarre
affects that gravitational lensing can
create.
Um,
and as I mentioned,
in some cases these are scientifically
useful things because you can determine
the distribution of the mass that's
causing the lending questions. Yes.
Well, uh, what you have to do,
it depends a little bit on the exact mass
distribution of the lens. In this case,
I think they're assuming a
point source. And so, uh,
it is in general true that if
there's a gravitational lens,
you end up seeing more light than you
otherwise would because it's focused in
towards you.
So the total amount of light that you
see if you're seeing a lens to object is
typically larger than the amount you
would see in the absence of Lens.
So there are more paths of light that
are curved towards you that are curved
away from.
If you're standing over on the side,
you'll lose a little bit of the light
because it will be curved in some other
direction. Uh, and so there are more
different way you can see the thing for,
you know, it's uh, kind of an
early 20th century art thing.
You can see the same object from two
different sides at once. Uh, and uh,
you get these curious distortions.
Yes.
If you're looking into a
galaxy cluster in there,
a lot of streets are a lot of galaxies
and you don't know the mass of the galaxy.
You're trying to turn it mass,
the one that's causing it. Yeah.
How do you know what strengths
belong to which gallon?
What streets belong to
which ground galaxies. Okay.
You know that the streaks must come from
galaxies that are located behind the
galaxy cluster that are not themselves
part of the galaxy cluster. Uh,
and in order to understand what
that streak is, in principle,
you'd need to know the exact
shape and size of that galaxy.
You can go and take a spectrum of the
thing and figure out how far away it is
and what the relative distances
are. Uh, but you in principle,
you would need to know the exact shape
of that galaxy before it was distorted,
which you don't know.
And so what you have to do to interpret
these things is to take many streaks and
assume that the galaxies that
cause them are kind of normal,
a normal distribution of
galaxies, shapes. And so it's,
it's more of a statistical process then
using them one at a time. In that case,
the quasars are a little easier to deal
with because you know that their points.
Um, and uh, there's,
there are various kinds of limits to
how much information you can get out of
this. And it's, it's,
it's quite tricky to do.
What's easy to do is the thing
that they did in that picture.
You imagine that there's a mass in the
way and you figure out what happens to
the light from the background.
What's hard to do is to observe
the light in the background,
not know what it ought to look like,
really and infer what the
mass distribution is. That's
a harder problem. And the,
and there's a lot of theoretical effort
at the moment going into trying to solve
that problem of here's what you see,
uh,
infer what the mass distribution it has
to be in order for you to see that. Yes.
Have we ever observed like,
you know,
sort of the perfect bun senior
we have there, we have a ringer.
Yes, there are some Einstein rings.
Uh, I don't have them here. Uh,
Hubble Space Telescope has
observed a bunch of these things.
Typically they're not full rings because
the mass distribution is not perfectly
symmetric, but there are
there, as you can see,
you can see those were taught
kind of little arcs. Uh,
and if you get it set
up just the right way,
the arc can go a large fraction
of the way around the circle.
So these are kind of fun
things to observe and also, uh,
give you useful information.
So that's the second of
the post Newtonian effects.
The first with the procession of the
Perry Kilian. Now the deflection of light,
uh, moving on, uh,
number three here is what
we talked about last time,
which is the gravitational red shift.
Uh,
and here we have a delta lambda
over lambda or alternatively,
uh, in the case of the problems that
you're working on the pulse period, uh,
in either case, these are usually
given the letter z. That's red shift.
Yeah.
That's a definition of this, this
quantity Z, which is often used, uh,
and uh,
this is equal to this quantity.
Uh,
and this is the
Schwarzer old radius
of,
uh,
some mass.
Yeah.
And this are is the distance
of
the light source.
Okay.
From that mass.
And
what this equation signifies
is how much red shift is there.
If you observe this thing when
you are sitting at infinity,
do you observe from
infinite
distance?
And what do I mean by infinite distance?
What I mean is that rs over
our goes to zero. That's what,
that's what infinite. That's what
infinite army did in this case.
So you're sitting out there a long,
long,
long way away from any
gravitational effect.
You're looking at a light that is
emitted inside a gravitational field,
relatively close to some mass. That
light is red, shifted by this amount.
Uh, and pulse periods are also
lengthened by the same amount.
And I'll come back to that in a minute.
Uh,
one thing I want to say right now is
what happens if you are an observer and
you're not infinitely far away?
What happens if you're just a little bit
further away than the light sources or
perhaps even if you're closer to the
object than the light sources? Uh,
and, uh, in that case, if
the observer is not at infinity,
then the observed red shift
a is equal to the red shift,
uh,
from the source to infinity,
which you can calculate by this calculated
by this formula minus the red shift
from the observer
to infinity,
which you can also calculate with
that same, uh, with that same formula.
So you have to subtract a two things.
Basically what happens is
imagine the light going from,
it starts out at the source,
it goes to the Observer,
and then it keeps going all the way
out to infinity. And you want to ask,
what is the observers?
See,
the observer sees that portion of the
red shift that happens between the source
and the Observer.
So to figure out what that is,
you figure out the red shift
from the source to infinity.
You figure out the retro from
the Observer to Infinity,
and you subtract those things,
and that gives you the red
shift from the Observer,
from the source to the
Observer. Okay? Yes.
Ah, no, no, no. But look what happens
when rns over R is equal to zero.
That means there's no red shift.
It doesn't mean that the way
the observed wavelength is zero,
it meets the change in the
wavelength is zero. Yeah,
that's important. Uh, and uh, in the, uh,
just to comment on the problem set here,
uh,
the idea on the second part of the
problem of the problem set is a,
you do have an observer at infinity.
So here's The Observer.
Here's some neutron star and you have a
light source that can either be on the
surface of the neutron star or it can
be raised off the surface of the neutron
star. And, uh, basically what you're,
what you're observing is the change
in the light source. So this has some,
has some red shift,
some pretty large red shift cause it's
sitting on the surface of a neutron star.
This because it's further away from the
neutron star has slightly less red shift.
And what you are interested in
is the change in the red shift.
And the idea behind the problem is,
uh,
you want to set this up so that that
change in the red shift is the same as the
change in the red shift
due to the doppler shift.
If this whole thing was in orbit around
something that's the plan of that, uh,
that,
that particular problem.
Okay. So that's the third, uh, uh,
of the, uh, post Newtonian relativistic
effects. And there's a fourth one.
The fourth is gravitational waves,
which, uh, I may have time to come
back and talk about in detail. Uh,
at the moment though, I just want to say
what the effect of these things is. Uh,
rather than talk in detail
about what they are,
the effect is that the
orbital period decreases.
Yeah.
It turns out this is a relatively small,
uh,
and uh,
it is not observed in the solar system.
Yeah.
Even, uh, even in mercury, which has
the strongest relativistic effect.
Okay.
So those are four,
uh,
post Newtonian effects
of general relativity.
And what I want to talk about now
is what has become probably the best
laboratory for general relativity,
uh,
that we know of Prom
with general relativity.
You can't actually study it
all that much in the lab. Uh,
because in order to study,
you need strong gravitational forces
and it's very difficult to create strong
gravitational forces in a laboratory.
Uh, what would you need to do?
You'd need to take some massive
object, crush it down to, you know,
the size of a black hole or something
and have it sit there and your lab.
And this is not something that one can do.
And so you have to go and
look at astronomical objects
in order to find suitable
situations in which to study
these relativistic effects.
So the best lab for general
relativity lab for g are here is uh,
uh, a set of objects and
one object in particular,
which is referred to as
the binary pulse are, uh,
this is discussed in the readings
for this week's problem set. Uh,
the discovery of this particular object
led to a Nobel prize for its discovers.
Uh, and, uh, uh, uh, that's what's
discussed in that article. So,
uh, the first thing to talk about
here is what is a pulse are.
So Paul Stars were discovered
in the late 19, uh, 1960s.
Okay.
Uh,
okay.
A woman named Jocelyn Bell and she,
uh,
wired up a whole field in Cambridge,
England to make the,
to make it behave like a
radio telescope and, uh,
discovered that there
were objects in the sky,
celestial objects that seem to be
emitting pulses of radio waves.
So the observed signature of these things,
what was observed his
pulses of radio waves.
So you get kind of a blip every few
seconds it goes, blip, blip, blip, blip,
and so forth. And, uh,
these pulses come by.
Uh,
so the pulsations happen,
uh, once, uh, it's sort of, uh, with,
with a period of somewhere between
milliseconds and 10 seconds.
So they come at you pretty rapidly.
Most of them are a few seconds
or maybe a fraction of a second.
So these are blipping away
and they had no idea what these were.
And the first four of them,
uh,
they gave the nickname LGM one
l g M to l g m three LGM for,
for little green men. Uh, because the
thought was that these might actually,
they thought briefly that these might
be signals from some extra terrestrial
intelligence cause you know,
it's a very regular signal.
It's hard to imagine how
those could have been created.
But fortunately before they
publish their paper, uh,
somebody suggested a better solution,
which turns out to be correct.
That what these things are, are, uh,
rotating a magnetized
a neutron stars.
And this was the first direct evidence
that neutron stars existed. Uh,
and the reason they thought they were
neutron stars, this is because, uh,
the speed with which these things pulsed,
um,
is supposed to be reflected in the
rotation of these neutron stars.
And something that rotates 10 times a
second had better be pretty small. Uh,
and so there was a strong size
limits on the neutron stars. Uh,
it's not gonna matter too much
exactly what these things are.
Uh,
but I'm going to explain it to you anyway,
but don't worry too much about it
for the purposes of relativity.
The key point here is that it's
an extremely accurate clock,
that you get these blips coming out
of the thing and that creates a very
accurate clock and then you can see
very small changes in the pulse rate of
these things. So now let me just
briefly tell you what these are. Oh,
I should mention, uh, so, uh,
the discovery of neutron stars,
this was a very big deal.
This was the first strongly relativistic
object that had ever been discovered
and they awarded a Nobel prize to
Joslin Bells, thesis supervisor, uh,
and there is some feeling among some
folks that this was an injustice.
Uh, and so there is, uh,
people discuss the, uh,
the story of Jocelyn Bell and
the discovery of, of Paul SARS.
Uh,
to her credit bell has never complained
a bell and the discovery of pulse.
Ah Ha. Oh yes. Well, that's actually an
interesting question. The question is,
did the thesis advisor do anything
as a thesis advisor? Myself,
I take that question seriously. Well,
this is the whole debate about, well,
who should have gotten the Nobel prize?
It,
the thesis supervisor thought up
the experiment and Bell did it.
So who ought to get the credit for that?
Uh,
it's actually a subtle question and it
bears on a problem for or whatever it is
of, of this week's a, of this week's
homework. So it's worth thinking about.
Uh, Jocelyn bound the discovery of
pulse. Ours, uh, he also got the money.
Uh, that's not trivial sometimes.
Uh, and the moral of the story too,
it depends on who you ask for exactly.
The reason that you bring up a one
moral of the story is the Grad students,
particularly female Grad Students,
uh,
never get any credit
and that this is a great injustice.
Uh, as you get older, your attitude
toward this problem changes.
Uh, and uh, the alternative
moral is that, uh,
thinking and doing a is not the same,
are not the same, and that
thinking is better than doing, uh,
now, uh, what could raise various
objections and people have a,
to this line of thought.
And interestingly enough,
the next time they had to give a Nobel
prize for something to do with Paul
starts, which was the discovery
of the binary pulse are uh,
they did give the prize also to the
graduate student and it's the graduate
students,
uh,
description of what he did that you're
actually reading for this problem set.
So you can opine on this,
uh, uh, this topic yourself,
uh, for, uh, on the
problem set anyway. Um, a,
a, a matter of continuing controversy
in scientific circles. Uh,
but let me just briefly show you
what supposed to be happening here.
Here's a neutron star.
Okay.
Very dense thing. Yeah. And it's rotating.
So it's got some access of rotation here.
Take a different color.
So here's its axis of rotation and it's
rotating around its axis and it's also
got a magnetic field.
But the magnetic field,
the poll of the magnetic field is
not the same as the rotation pull.
That's true on the earth as well.
Magnetic north is not exactly in
the same place as, as true north,
the center of the Earth's rotation.
And if you're in northern Canada and you
try and follow a compass signal north,
uh, you're going to get yourself into
big trouble because you know, the,
the actual magnetic pole is
somewhere in northern Canada.
And if you're north of that,
you'll be going south when
you think you're going north.
Uh, anyway, imagine that.
Here's the magnetic fields.
Magnetic fields have these sort of
field lines that look like this. Uh,
and uh,
what happens in these things is that
there's radio emission coming out of the
magnetic poles. So there's radio
emission coming out this way.
And so, uh, if you're
observing this from here,
say,
uh,
you see a radio emission when the
poll was pointing towards you,
but then, uh, if the thing is
rotating, then half a rotation later,
so later,
uh,
but not too much later because this
thing rotates really quickly. Uh,
here's the neutron star still and now
the pole's over here because it's rotated
around by a factor of
two, uh, by, by half,
by half a rotation.
So now the radio emissions coming this
and if you're still sitting observing the
thing down here, you don't see
anything. So this is on and this is off.
So you watched this Paul, it
started like a lighthouse. You know,
a lighthouse has a beam of light
and when it's pointing towards you,
you see light. And then as it's going
around in a circle, you don't see light,
then it points towards UGC light again.
And so the consequence of this is that
you get something that looks like radio.
If you plot radio emission versus time,
you get these very regularly spaced blips.
Uh,
and it is the time between one
blip in the next. That's the uh,
pulse period,
pulse period.
And so for our purposes here, I mean,
pulsars are very interesting objects,
but we're not going to go into
them in any depth as objects.
The key thing is that it's got this
really accurate clock on it. And when,
if you imagine a pulse are in orbit around
something, when it comes towards you,
each one of these blips
happens a little closer to you.
So the light travel time
from the blip to you is less.
And so it seems like the blips happened
closer together because each one of
them's emitted a little closer towards
you. Similarly, when it's going away,
each blip is emitted a little further
away. It takes extra time to get to you.
And the pulse period,
the length of time between the pulses
appears to be longer by how much, uh,
by exactly the amount that the doppler
shift formula, uh, would suggest.
And so the pulse period
obeys the same rules, uh,
in terms of its length as
a wave lengths of light.
Okay.
So, uh, for example,
it is true that a delta pulse period
over pulse period a is equal to the usual
doppler shift formula.
Yeah.
Which is approximately
equal to VR oversee, uh,
in the Newtonian approximation.
Oh,
and I should say in problem
one on the problem set,
you can use the Newtonian approximation
because as you'll discover,
the velocity of the object as it goes
around in its orbit is significantly less
than the speed of light.
Okay.
So they discovered this binary pulse are
with a short orbital period. The orbital
period. This is now the orbital period,
uh, is around eight hours,
which is pretty short,
but it's still not very relativistic,
but you can measure these things. Two,
incredible accuracy,
okay?
So you can not only see the
velocity curve that we're used to,
you can also see tiny deviations
from the Newtonian velocity curve.
And from those tiny deviations
from the Newtonian velocity curve,
you can see these posts, Newtonian
effects, uh, in particular, it turns out,
so this is an ellipse.
It's in an elliptical orbit.
It's not a circular orbit,
it's a highly elliptical orbit.
And you can see the precession
of the Perry Asteron
as the elliptic city as
the direction of the orbit.
As the position of the orbit changes,
you can see the procession of the Perry
Asteron and the procession of the Perry
Astro. It happens at the rate
of four degrees per year.
Now compare that to mercury in which the
same effect can be observed at 43 arc
seconds per century.
So this is a much stronger effect.
Okay?
Uh, okay. You can also see
the gravitational red shift.
Now,
let me show you how this comes about.
Uh, but you, you have to be careful
about exactly what you're seeing.
You're not seeing the gravitational
redshift due to the fact that the clock is
sitting on a neutron star, uh,
because, okay, so you're seeing
the effect of the
companion object of this
other object in the system,
which happens to be also a neutron star,
but not a pulse are.
And what happens is this,
here's your clock and it's going around
in some kind of elliptical orbit.
Uh, here's the center of
mass. Here's the other.
So there's a clock that's
going around like this,
and then there's some other object.
It's going around like this.
Yeah,
there are approximately the same mass.
And so sometimes these objects are
close to each other. Uh, for example,
oops. Here, when they're here and here,
uh,
this is called this position one,
and then later on, half an orbit later,
they're out here in position two,
and this one's gone all
the way out to here.
Okay?
Uh,
so at position one,
uh,
the objects are close
and sold. The clock has to, uh,
go is red shifted by the
presence of the other object.
Uh, and so it has to, uh, if there's
a red shift due to the other object,
which is nearby, objects
are close. So the red shift,
yeah.
Caused by the other object,
other object is large.
Okay.
At position two,
the distance to the other object as
much greater distance is greater.
And so red shift is less.
Now,
it's also true that there's a red shift
cost by the fact that this clock is
sitting on a neutron star.
But the thing about that red shift is it
doesn't change during the course of the
orbit.
So you can't actually tell that it's there
because that's one of the differences
between measuring pulse periods of,
uh,
of Paul Stars and measuring wavelengths
of light with the spectral features in,
in light. You know, what
it's supposed to be.
If it isn't red shifted in
the case of the pulse, ours,
you don't know in advance what
the pulse period ought to be.
So you can't tell what it,
what it should be if there
was no gravitational field
or was no doppler shift.
All that you can tell is the amount by
which it changes during the course of an
orbital period. And so
you're comparing, uh, uh,
the red shift when the objects are in
this position to the red shift of the
objects in this position, the red
shift caused by the pulse are itself,
doesn't change,
but the red shift caused by where it's
companion is and the gravitational force
exerted by the companion does
change. The consequence, by the way,
is that if these things
are in a circular orbit,
you can't see the gravitational redshift
cause they're always the same distance
away from each other. And the
gravitational redshift doesn't change.
There is a gravitational red shift,
but it doesn't change during
the course of the period.
And it's the change that you can observe.
Yes.
So it just gets red ship docked to the
frequency of the light in the pulses is,
it's the time. It's the time
between pulses. Uh, yeah.
There you could imagine that the
pulses might have a spectral feature.
And then you would, then you would see
it in the spectral feature too. In fact,
that's extremely hard to have that.
That doesn't happen. It's, it's a,
it's a continuum, a of
light. So it's the type,
what you observe is the time between
pulses and that's a can be observed
extremely accurately.
You get 20 decimal places of accuracy.
It's really kind of frightening.
Yes.
Well, if it's a circular orbit,
know if there's a circular orbit,
they're always the same
distance around each other.
They're chasing each other in a circle.
That's what it means
to be a circular orbit.
Has every point on the orbit is the same
distance to the center for both objects.
So each object is the same distance
from the center of mass at all times.
That's what makes it a circular orbit.
And they're always on the opposite
side of the center of mass.
So the distance between them is
always the same. For a circular orbit,
I'll draw it. Uh, here we go.
Here's the center of mass.
Supposing these objects are the same mass
as each other. So here's one of them.
It's going around this way. And here it
is right now. And here's the other object.
It's going around this way
and here it is right now.
And they're just going to
march around this circle.
Each being on the opposite
side of the center.
And the distance between the won't change.
Oh,
they only overlap if there,
if the two objects are the same mass.
Uh, so if one object is
more massive than the other,
then you've got a little
circle going this way, uh,
and wipes and a big circle going this way.
Uh,
let's see.
It would it have to be there and then
they're still the same distance from each
other at every point along the way because
each one of them is always the same
distance from the center
of mass in the middle.
And they're always on opposite sides.
Okay.
Ah,
so the way you lips his work is,
so here's an ellipse and the
lips can be bigger little,
here's an ellipse they're doing ellipses,
and the center of mass is
at one focus of the ellipse.
It's not at the center of the ellipse.
That's the key thing. Uh, and so at,
when they're your furthest
away from the focus,
you have a long distance from the center.
When you're closer, you're closer.
And it's because each one of these things,
you don't maintain a constant
distance from the center of mass.
Okay?
Uh,
so because of this effect
in elliptical orbits,
in Binary pulsars and elliptical orbit,
you can observe the
gravitational red shift also.
And this is what they got the
Nobel prize for. Really. Uh,
you can see that the orbital period
decreases. It's getting shorter.
The two objects are spiraling in together,
decreases due to gravitational waves.
So you can observe three different posts,
Newtonian effects in
these systems. So, uh,
so this constitutes a serious test of
general relativity in the following way.
If you could do only the Newtonian
only Newtonian measurements,
what would you get?
Well,
we did this before for the planets.
What you can get out of a Newtonian
measurement to velocity. Remember,
what you're doing is you're
measuring the doppler shift,
you're measuring radial velocity.
What you get is a, you can determine,
uh, m total, the total mass of the system.
If you know the inclination,
that's something we tended to leave out.
We always claimed these things are
edge on cause it makes the calculations
easier.
But in fact you get a different answer
depending on what the inclination is and
you don't necessarily know the
inclination. So if you now measure,
yeah,
the precession
okay
of the Perry Astro
then this also the amount of that also
depends on m one m two the two masses and
the inclination.
So you can solve for the inclination now
is it isn't actually
precisely how you do it,
but conceptually this is how it works.
You're now solve for the inclination.
You then know, uh, m total,
but not each individual mass
m one m two and the inclination,
this is I,
right, but you don't know
the individual masses. Now,
if both objects were pulsars
and you could see both orbits,
then you would also know, uh, the, the
individual, uh, masses. But you don't,
you only see one of these objects.
Okay.
So now the next effect is
gravitational red shift.
And this again depends in a different way.
On m one m two and the inclination had,
so now,
uh,
you can solve for m one and since
you know they're the total mass,
you also get him to,
okay.
So at this point,
you know,
m one m two and the inclination,
what's happening here is that
each time you measure an effect,
you get an additional constraint.
And you started out having a
three unknowns and what equation?
Uh, and of course you can't solve for
three unknowns with only one equation,
but then you observe two more effect.
So now you have three
unknowns and three equations.
So now you can solve for all
of these things. Now, you know,
everything at this point you can predict
what the period change should
be because you know everything,
then you can measure that.
And so you have a specific prediction
of created from general relativity.
You can measure this effect,
uh,
and the prediction turns out to be correct
to within the measurement terrorists
and the measurement errors are getting
more precise all the time because as time
goes on,
the amount of change in the period since
they first observe it increases because
the periods changing more,
it's slowing down and slowing the period,
the periods getting faster and faster.
The object serve are falling in. Uh,
and so over time, uh,
that change mounts up,
you can measure it better and
better and better as time goes on.
And so the precision of this test of
general relativity is going up all the
time.
So it is now clear,
uh,
that general relativity is a correct
to some number of decimal places is,
uh,
I'm going to put correct in quotes
because it depends how accurately you can
measure it,
but the accuracy is going up all the
time in the post Newtonian approximation.
Remember,
all these affect our posts,
Newtonian only actually,
they've now observed a couple of post
post Newtonian effect, which are the next,
uh, the next term in the, uh, in
the series expansion. But, uh,
and those are also correct, but they're
not measured as precisely yet. Uh, so,
so it's clear that general relativity
is correct as long as everything is,
is still pretty close to, uh, um,
it's still pretty close
to the Newtonian thing.
You can actually still have orbits,
but you could imagine a theory
which is like Newton,
uh,
in the first term of the expansion,
like general relativity
in the second term,
the post Newtonian term,
but different
at very,
uh,
strong in very strong
gravitational fields.
So you've got to get the first term to
work and it's got to come out like Newton,
you've got to get the second term to work.
It's got to come out like
general relativity. But then, uh,
you can imagine all sorts of different
functions that work with this work with
this and are different in
the higher order terms.
And the higher order terms are the things
that give rise to all these exciting
effects. Like, uh, it's like event
horizons and things like that. So,
uh, what would be nice, it would be good,
uh,
to have some way of testing strong field
effects. And by that I mean
situations in which, uh,
the Schwartz showed radius over our,
uh,
becomes close to one because in that case,
all the terms in this series
expansion contributing.
And if you can get it,
if the theory is right there,
then all the terms have to be the same.
And you don't have this nagging doubt
about whether you could come up with some
theory that looks like Newton in the same
way that general relativity looks like
Newton Buddies, different, uh, uh,
once you get higher order terms,
looks like general relativity
and the second term,
but turns out to be a totally
different theory. Needless to say,
the theorists have come up
with a literally an infinite
number of such theories
because there's a whole infinite
family of things which satisfy this,
satisfy this and look different
at the upper level. So, uh,
what we're going to talk about next
time is how one might go about,
uh,
testing strong field relativity.
This is a subject close to my heart
because it's what I do for a living. Uh,
and we'll talk about it on Thursday.